i have experience developing cloud  applications but i need to prove that i  am a cloud developer i wonder what my  options are  have you considered the professional  cloud developer certification by google  cloud it basically is professional stamp  of approval  tell me more i'm curious well it tests  your understanding of designing  developing troubleshooting and managing  a robust and scalable cloud native  application but how do i know if i'm  ready  it's not magic just review the sample  questions and familiarize yourself with  the format of the exam  well you do need to be proficient with  at least one programming language though  yeah yeah yeah that makes sense since  it's a developer certification okay i'll  do it